[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis guten abend und
herzlich willkommen den sport hat
norbert lehmann für sie
die großen themen heute
der tag nach dem trial und die spannende
frage wer sich beim tv dreikampf ums
kanzleramt am besten geschlagen hat
afghanistan helfen aber wie die welt
will not und hunger im krisenland
bekämpfen dabei aber möglichst nicht den
taliban entgegenkommen
und ein pieks in der märchenlandschaft
eine woche lang sollen ungewöhnliche
aktionen das stocken der impf tempo in
deutschland wieder in schwung bringen
während scholz laschet um bernburg nach
dem trial auf rückenwind für den
endspurt ums kanzleramt offen über die
anderen parteien kritik auf die fdp und
die linke hätten sich jeweils andere
themenschwerpunkte im fernsehduell
gewünscht der sozialdemokrat scholz
schnitt bei den zuschauerinnen und
zuschauern zwar am besten ab aber auch
die union und die grünen sehen sich nach
dem trial bestärkt britta spiekermann
olaf scholz heute bei betriebs- und
personalräten in stuttgart applaus für
einen der sich besonders entspannt gibt
nach dem tv-duell bildts umfragen sahen
ihn gestern formen laschet mit dem
rücken zur wand schreibt gestern auf
angriff liefert sich mit scholz einen
schlagabtausch über das problem
geldwäsche bei einer razzia im
bundesfinanzministerium
berbalk zwischendurch nur zuschauerin
das trial gerät mitunter zum duell es
ist schon ein wunder wie sie selbst in
diesem fall
wenn eine staatsanwaltschaft in ihr
ministerium kommt und untersuchungen
durchführt eine solche schönrederei an
den tag legen kann die
staatsanwaltschaft hat eine untersuchung
in köln und für die untersuchung die sie
dort macht braucht sie auskünfte sie hat
keine untersuchungen im hinblick auf
dieses ministerium und weil sie das so
darstellen wecken sie an falschen
eindruck die kanzlerkandidatin der
grünen sieht schwere versäumnisse bei
spd und union eins der größten probleme
auch mit blick auf den staatshaushalt
ist dass dem staat rund 50 milliarden
euro jährlich durch
steuerbetrug durch geldwäsche durch
kriminelle aktivitäten durch die lappen
gehen steuern renten bürgerversicherung
klima koalitionsoptionen streit und
konturen es war in der tat einen
wahlkampf format hoch informativ und man
hat eben auch gesehen dass es am ende
wenn die
koalitionsverhandlungen anstehen holprig
werden kann weil sehr unterschiedliche
positionen ausgetauscht worden sind die
opposition positioniert sich heute
erneut wenn es nach der wahl eine
rechnerische mehrheit aus spd grünen und
linken gibt dann sollten wir sehr
ernsthaft darüber reden wie wir zu einem
politikwechsel kommen die entlastung für
den mittelstand wie sieht es mit der
steuerpolitik aus wie gehen wir immer
noch mit der illegalen zuwanderung um
das sind ja auch alles probleme die
einfach liegengelassen wertloses klar
wir schließen etwas aus nämlich ein
links trifft in deutschland wir
schließen aus höhere steuern wir
schließen aus aufweichen der
schuldenbremse ein großer teil der
wählerinnen und wähler ist laut umfragen
noch unentschlossen nach dem tv-duell
ist vor dem endspurt noch zwei wochen
bis zur bundestagswahl und dazu schack
und männer die aus unserem
hauptstadtstudio stadt kommt allawi
gehen laschet stolzenberg und ihre
parteien nach dem trainer jetzt in
dieser heiße letzte phase dieses
wahlkampfes
ja alle mobilisieren jetzt natürlich
noch mal die reserven die sie haben
armin laschet hat heute angekündigt dass
angela merkel da jetzt noch zwei
zusätzliche wahlkampftermine
mit bestreiten soll also man geht
nochmal mit allem was man hat hier auf
stimmenfang und man übt sich auch ein
bisschen den selbstmotivation einer der
sätze die man hier in berlin immer
häufiger hört ist man muss nicht
stärkste partei werden um ins
bundeskanzleramt
einzuziehen ist könnte auch platz platz
zwei reichen und stadt also jetzt
verbissen um platz eins zu kämpfen merkt
man auch dass alle parteien anfangen man
nach rechts sondern links zu schauen mit
wem sie möglicherweise in verhandlungen
eintreten können es gibt
lockerungsübungen wir haben wolfgang
kubicki von der fdp gehört der gestern
die mauern in richtung spd ein bisschen
abgebaut hat und gesagt hat prinzipiell
kann man sich auch da gespräche
vorstellen und so konzentrieren sich
jetzt nach und nach alle auf schon auf
den zeitpunkt nach der wahl wo
möglicherweise die kleinen parteien
diejenigen sind die mit darüber
entscheiden wir haben ende ins
kanzleramt kommt danke für diese
einschätzung stadt mutterleib energy den
bundestags parteien die nicht beim trial
vertreten waren treffen heute im zdf
aufeinander afd fdp linke und csu im
schlagabtausch direkt nach dieser
sendung
in sachsen anhalt steht die sogenannte
deutschland koalition mehr als drei
monate nach der landtagswahl haben cdu
spd und fdp den koalitionsvertrag
unterzeichnet schwerpunkte sind unter
anderem digitalisierung strukturwandel
unter kohleausstieg am donnerstag stellt
sich ministerpräsident haseloff im
landtag zur wiederwahl
in genf gab es heute eine un
geberkonferenz für afghanistan
denn die not dort ist groß tag für tag
verschlechtert sich die lage in dem
ohnehin armen land mehr als 18 millionen
menschen sind auf humanitäre hilfe
angewiesen
es fehlen lebensmittel wasser
medikamente
die etwa 2500 kliniken können ohne
hilfsgelder aus dem ausland nur schwer
weiter arbeiten katrin eigendorf aus der
afghanischen hauptstadt
auf der säuglingsstation des indira
gandhi krankenhauses kämpft der kleine
nummern um sein leben und eigentlich
könnte er es schaffen doch es sind zu
viele
die sauerstoff geräte reichen nicht aus
es gibt nicht genug medikamente setzt
die betten müssen die ärzte oft mit zwei
babys belegen
ich bin sehr traurig wenn ich sehe dass
patienten in einem kritischen zustand
kommen weil wir keine mittel haben sowie
medikamente ist auch keine notversorgung
es sind dramatische zustände und es sind
vor allem die mütter die an den betten
bangen über haar ist mit ihren beiden
kindern hier sohn und tochter leiden an
den folgen einer schweren unterernährung
ich bin so müde von dieser situation wir
besitzen nichts meine kinder ich und
mein mann uns allen geht es sehr
schlecht
40 prozent aller afghanischen kinder
unter fünf jahren leiden an den folgen
von unterernährung und jetzt droht sich
die situation zu verschärfen
afghanistan braucht dringend
internationale hilfe
deswegen hat uns das ärzte-team dieses
kinderkrankenhauses hier durch alle
räume geführt um uns zu zeigen es fehlt
an allem an antibiotika und
sauerstoffgeräten an wirklich den
notwendigsten medikamenten um ihr leben
zu retten jeder tag zählt sagen die
kinderärzte und auch das kinderhilfswerk
der vereinten nationen warnt vor einem
kollaps des gesundheitssystems
leidtragende wären sie die schwächsten
und um die schwächsten afghanistan zu
unterstützen heute die un geberkonferenz
in genf und dort ist für uns patricia
wiedemeier patricia ist das geld
zusammen gekommen dass für die
humanitäre hilfe benötigt wird
also der un-generalsekretär hat vor 2
stunden verkündet dass eine summe von
1,1 milliarden us dollar
zusammengekommen ist und es könnte noch
weitaus mehr werden denn die konferenz
läuft noch wie man hier hinter mir im
gebäude sieht und es könnte noch
deutlich mehr werden 100 millionen davon
kommen aus deutschland und weitere 500
millionen wurden in aussicht gestellt
aber dieses geld geht nicht nur an die
humanitäre hilfe in afghanistan auch
nachbarländer wie zum beispiel pakistan
oder usbekistan bekommen gelder da sie
ja flüchtlinge aufnehmen also unterm
strich war es ein großer erfolg wie
lange dieses geld aber reichen wird das
ist fraglich das geld ist dabei sind es
denn ist es denn an konkrete bedingungen
geknüpft worden zb dass die taliban die
frauenrechte nicht einschränken dürfen
nein das ist nicht so bei humanitärer
hilfe sei das nicht der fall das sei nie
an politische forderungen gebunden in
keinem land auch nicht in afghanistan
das hat heute außenminister maß hier
deutlich gemacht jetzt gehe ist wirklich
nur darum den hungertod zu vermeiden
anders ist das wenn es um
entwicklungshilfe geht dann muss man
sich an politische forderungen halten
dann müssten die taliban zum beispiel
frauenrechte menschenrechte natürlich
bewahren sie müssten eine gemäßigtere
regierung bilden und auch afghanistan
dürfe dann nicht mehr ein hort des
terrorismus seien das war hier heute
immer wieder zu hören dankeschön
patrizier wedemeyer
die deutsche umwelthilfe zieht wegen der
klimapolitik mehrerer landesregierung
vor das bundesverfassungsgericht
zusammen mit kindern und jungen
erwachsenen legte der verband heute
klage ein gegen hessen
mecklenburg-vorpommern das saarland
sachsen und sachsen anhalt sie sollen
dadurch dazu gezwungen werden landes
klimaschutzgesetze zu verabschieden
im museum beim einkaufen vom konzert
alles ohne termin mit einer aktionswoche
will die bundesregierung mehr menschen
zum impfen gegen korona bewegen denn
seit anfang juni geht die zahl der
verabreichten dosen zurück dadurch
bewegt sich die bundesweite impfquote
kaum noch und liegt bei rund 62 prozent
und es gibt große regionale unterschiede
spitzenreiter bremen hat fast 73 prozent
der bevölkerung vollständig geimpft beim
schlusslicht sachsen sind es gerade mal
53 prozent steffi buss
impfen zwischen hexenküche und feen
schloss ein kinderspielplatz in einem
dresdner einkaufszentrum ist karola
bedingt gerade geschlossen und wird so
mal schnell für eine mobile impfaktion
genutzt für einem pieks im zauberschloss
stehen die dresdner schlange als man
konnte auch ohne termine herkommen und
ja das hat alles super geklappt das war
jetzt klar dass einfache ohne termin und
es bot sich jetzt an und jordan youtube
wahrscheinlich nehmen noch immer gibt es
viele die den weg zu impfzentren und
impfen mit termin scheuen die zu
erreichen ist jetzt das ziel
schlusslicht beim impfen ist dass
sachsen wo gerade mal 53 prozent
vollständig geimpft sind wir wissen halt
auch in sachsen dass wir 20 21% nie
erreichen werden sie lehnen es ab oder
können aus medizinischen gründen aus
welchen gründen auch immer dieses
angebot nicht annehmen wir wissen also
auch und das ist das was wir uns
konzentrieren dass 20 prozent
grundsätzlich bereit sind also noch
bereit sind und die versuchen wir mit
solchen aktionen wie hier ganz nahe zu
erreichen zb zur zeit gerade bei einem
kleinen stadtfest die dresdner laden ein
zu speis und trank und zum impfen also
wir haben mit dem mobilen im teams
absolut positive erfahrungen gemacht
weil wir sie überall dorthin schicken wo
die menschen sind ob in einkaufszentren
oder zur veranstaltung ins
fußballstadion egal wo und überall
finden wir menschen die sagen also wenn
die von hier sind da kann ich auch
hingehen
unkompliziert und einfach mal nebenbei
den pigs abholen es scheint als ob das
inzwischen die beste möglichkeit ist die
menschen zu erreichen
ganz ohne zusatzkosten mit bus und bahn
quer durch deutschland reisen das können
ab heute abonnenten des öffentlichen
nahverkehrs
die aktion gilt allerdings nur für zwei
wochen und richtet sich an stammkunden
des rpnv die verkehrsunternehmen wollen
sich damit bei all denen bedanken die
auch während der pandemie bus und bahn
die treue gehalten haben wer das angebot
nutzen will muss sich vorher online
registrieren
und wir kommen jetzt zum tennis finale
der männer bei den us open letzten acht
ja und da hat der weltranglisten-zweite
daniel medwedew den
weltranglisten-ersten novak djokovic
geradezu vom platz gefegt mit 6 2 4 6 zu
4 und 6 zu viel in etwas mehr als zwei
stunden ein strahlender gewinner und ein
weinender verlierer
tränen der dankbarkeit bei novak
djokovic trotz seiner niederlage gegen
den russen daniil mehr dir der vom
publikum überschwänglich gefeiert der 20
fache grand slam champion aus serbien
ist tief gerührt dabei hat er immer
wieder mit seinem spiel verpasste als
zweiter spieler den grand slam also alle
vier großen turniere innerhalb eines
jahres zu gewinnen der 25-jährige mit
jeder bezwingt den weltranglisten ersten
djokovic glatt in drei sätzen und
gewinnt sein erstes grand slam turnier
überleben
morgen startet die fußball champions
league und die königsklasse kehrt zurück
ins free-tv die zusammenfassung der
spiele zu sehen bei uns im zdf immer
mittwochs um 23 uhr ja gleich morgen der
erste knaller der fc barcelona empfängt
bayern münchen
die ankunft der bayern in barcelona auch
mit dem zuletzt leicht angeschlagenen
robert lewandowski die stimmung gut wie
heute morgen im training kein wunder
nach dem überzeugenden 4 2 1
auswärtssieg bei rb leipzig jetzt geht
es in barcelona gegen den fc
das team ohne den abgewanderten weltstar
lionel messi
dementsprechend versuchen glaube ich
auch neue spieler die jetzt dazu
gekommen sind wie detail zum beispiel
auch verantwortung zu übernehmen die
rolle so gut es geht auch auszufüllen
und wir werden sehen was passiert aber
eine kalte dusche ist in spanien nicht
zu erwarten
das war's vom sport danken und dem
heute-journal freut sich marietta slomka
und viertel vor zehn auf sie sondern
gleich nach dem wetter können sie hier
den parteien vierkampf sehen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter das hoch
schwächelt allmählich das merken wir
daran dass von westen neue tiefs auf
ziehen schauer und gewitter mitbringen
aber es bleibt noch warm die warme luft
aus dem südwesten erreicht uns noch in
der nacht wird es ruhig werden es bildet
sich nebel die tiefsten temperaturen
liegen zwischen 7 und 15 grad und morgen
dann zunächst viel sonnenschein aber im
tagesverlauf vor allem von süden her
allmählich wolken verdichtung zum späten
nachmittag gibt es schauer und gewitter
als sonst ist es größtenteils trocken in
den frühstunden gibt allerdings nebel
temperaturen erreichen höchstwerte von
28 grad im südwesten deutschlands ganz
im norden sind es gerade mal 19 grad die
kommenden tage ja mittwoch sehr
durchwachsen mit schauern und gewittern
bis 26 grad oder am donnerstag ja da
wird nicht mehr ganz so warm werden bis
23 grad aber die schauer und gewitter
die bleiben uns erhalten ein schöner
abend